pour en parler nous recevons sur ce
plateau m christophe lèguevaques avocat
au barreau de paris et christophe
léguevaques bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation directe
sur rt france vous êtes l'un des avocats
qui comptent lancer cette action en
justice
concrètement comment se manifeste cette
pression des néo 10 c'est assez simple
quand vous êtes consommateur vous
recevez des appels téléphoniques et
textos des mails
oui vous avez des sous traitants d'aînés
disent qu'ils passaient chez vous qui
vous disent que c'est obligatoire que
c'est gratuit ce qui étonne double
mensonge et pour les personnes qui sont
pas informés ou qui font confiance 1 et
10 il accepte d'ouvrir la porte de
laisser les installateurs modifier les
équipements finalement c'est dans la
façon de faire la façon de rédiger les
courriers par exemple qui incite à avoir
un compteur linky
c'est plus qu'une citation c'est que
c'est un mensonge pur et simple
puisqu'on vous dit en permanence c'est
obligatoire et c'est gratuit or pour
c'est gratuit on a un texte de loi qui
le contraire donc problématique et pour
c'est obligatoire en revanche n'a pas de
textes de loi on ne sait pas sur quel
article s'appuie enelistes pour dire aux
consommateurs
vous ne pouvez pas refuser donc les
consommateurs ne sont pas obligés
d'accepter ces compteurs c'est ce que
nous affirmons et jusqu'à ce jour est né
dis ça a été dans l'impossibilité de
trouver un texte qu'ils soient français
ou européens
alors est ce que aujourd'hui ennedi
s'est tenue de retirer un boîtier six
ans consommateurs en fait la demande
si un consommateur en fait la demande et
le disque fera la sourde oreille dont
tony se passera rien c'est pour ça que
après une mise en demeure que nous avons
fait au mois de janvier une réponse qui
nous a pas satisfaite que nous avons
reçu dernièrement nous sommes obligés de
passer par la voie judiciaire pour
permettre aux consommateurs qui veulent
protéger de voir l'intervention neurones
d'un juge impartial qui jaillira aînés
10 arrêtez vous l'étiez de respecter à
la fois la vie privée le domicile privé
des consommateurs est retirée ou
n'installez pas les équipes en or
justement vous venez de l'évoquer ce qui
inquiète ce sont
les informations personnelles les
données personnelles la cnil avait
annoncé avoir mis en demeure les groupes
edf et angie à ce sujet c'était début
février
qu'est ce que leur reproche très
concrètement voulait le le compteur
linky s'est passé un peu un compteur qui
va mesurer votre consommation
d'électricité ça c'est la consommation
globale elle va mesurer aussi le
comportement d'achat en quelque sorte
des consommateurs en identifiant les
appareils qui sont connectés la durée
d'utilisation et même avec la signature
qui est blessée par ces appareils
il va pas elle va pouvoir déterminer
s'ils sont obsolètes ou nounous neuf et
ça ça va permettre ensuite à récupérer
ces informations à une et dix de les
revendre pour justement permettre à des
sociétés commerciales de vous proposer
de changer votre vie et équipements par
un nouveau que dit la loi à ce sujet là
c'est autorisé ou pas la loi que cela
doit l'infante liberté ou le ver jp des
européens prévoient que le consommateur
doit donner un accord particulier pour
l'utilisation qui sera faite des données
et la une et lisa bus de sa position
dominante
si vous voulez l'électricité ok cliquez
là et en même temps vous acceptez que
toutes les informations que je vais
récolter soit transféré à qui je veux
alors votre action en justice vous
conter la lancée d'une façon assez
originale finalement puisqu'il s'agira
d'une sorte de financement participatif
c'est bien cela alors ces patates et ça
c'est une action collective en droit
français nous avons une action de groupe
qui est un piège procédural que nous
voulons éviter dont nous avons inventé
ou re découvert l'action le collectif
conjointe qui permet à tout un tas de
personnes qui ne se connaissent pas de
se réunir autour d'une même procédure
pour agir ensemble et par cette réunion
devons réussi en quelque sorte à casser
les prix puisque une procédure normale
ou teinte de et 5000 euros
là nous arrivons à proposer les services
des avocats pour 200 euros et on va même
plus loin que je comprends que cette
200 euros ça peut être une somme
importante pour les consommateurs on a
réussi à lisser cette somme sur 24 mois
ce qui fait que c'est un abonnement à un
service qui coûte 1 8 euros par mois
quel sera l'impact juridique un très
concrètement de cette démarche
la démarche vise encore une fois à
protéger les consommateurs
c'est à dire qu'avec cette procédure
seuls ceux qui font la demande d'être
protégé par la justice seront justement
protéger
si vous n'êtes pas dans la procédure est
né dix pourra continuer à faire ce
qu'elle veut autrement dit on ne cherche
pas à interdire de linky on cherche
simplement à faire en sorte que ceux qui
n'en veulent pas soit entendu merci
beaucoup christophe léguevaques d'avoir
accepté notre invitation je rappelle que
vous êtes avocat au barreau de paris